مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تعد احد مظاهر
التفاعل في اطار ثوره التكنولوجيا لكنها
تلعب دورا ايضا في عالم السياسه منصه
تويتر دليل واضح
[موسيقى]
على تويتر فتح باب وجدل واسع بين مستخدم
على الصعيد السياسي اجج الصدامه الحزبي في
واشنطن بين الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمهوري
مع اختلاف نقاط التركيز بينهما
[موسيقى]
ايمان
فيهم الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن على ملكيه
ماسك لموقع تويتر في الاونه الاخيره ويقول
بعض الديمقراطيين انها قد تعرض قدره
المنصه على تامين البيانات الشخصيه
لمستخدمها للخطر
خاصه
مجلس النواب المحتمل العام المقبل فيقولون
ان الديمقراطيين يلاحقون ماسك بسبب
استعداده لمنح المحافظين صوتا على المنصه
ورددوا بان الانتقادات الديمقراطيه هي
محاوله مستتره للقضاء على الاصوات
المحافظه على الموقع وحجب ما اعتبروه حريه
التعبير
لحريه التعبير هو تهديد مباشره للحزب
الديمقراطي وحلفائه في وسائل الاعلام
القديمه بينما يهاجم الديمقراطيون اي جهد
لاعطاء الامريكيين صوتا اقوى سيكون
الجمهوريون يقضينا ضد التواطئ بين الشركات
التكنولوجيا الكبرى وهذه الاداره
صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال حذرت من انه
اصطدام قد ينذر بمزيد من الاستقطاب حول
الانترنت ودوري الحكومه في تنظيمه تصاعدات
في السنوات الاخيره دعوات للكونجرس لتحسين
حمايه الخصوصيه وتخفيف هيمنه شركات
التكنولوجيا العملاقه عبر تحديث القانون
الذي يحميها من المسؤوليه عن محتوى الطرف
الثالث